whenever somebody brings God into a
situation where nobody's talking about
God that person has so much craziness in
their head you know what I'm saying it
doesn't matter if you have a lot of
money it doesn't matter if you're a high
Performing Artist it doesn't matter if
you bring up God and nobody's talking
about God crazy if you're at church and
you start talking about God maybe you're
not
crazy but dude one time I was at
In-N-Out by
myself this was
actually three or four weeks
ago I was at In-N-Out by
myself at about 11:30 at night after my
show in coina
okay let me let me accentuate this again
by myself self sitting
down was it annoying yes did people want
to take pictures yes did people say I
don't want to be that guy but then
subsequently we're that guy yes and it's
all good all right but a guy came up to
me and said christalia and I look at him
and say yeah what's up man and he says I
just want to tell
you God loves
you and in my head
immediately
crazy but I say oh thanks man because
you know the guy means well and honestly
I love him because we're all people just
trying to navigate through this world
but he says God loves you and I said oh
yeah he said yeah God loves you in his
heart and I ever and I always said to
myself if I ever met somebody of note if
I ever met somebody who was like a
celebrity or something like that I would
just look them in the eyes and let them
know that God loves them so God loves
you and I go like this oh cool well
thanks man
and he said have a great day night and
he left and the whole time in my head I
was thinking hey butd
chist but it happened dude how amazing
is it that people just come up to you
sometimes and say if you're a hot chick
God bless you dude God bless you for
real